[Music]
j
k news jk news so reverend
hey news
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
years hit me all right so
um not that i condone uh
trying to be a player or anything like
that has anyone
uh in this room ever gone through like i
want to be a player and like you know
try to date multiple people at a time
post pandy baby it's going down
let's go are you condemning players
right now i'm not condemning i'm just i
just don't personally condone it i'm a
married man
ah he's a married man with a ring on his
finger
can't you be married and still condone
it though
interesting good point
hey whatever we're not for you whatever
it's your boat yeah whatever floats your
boat yeah have anyone
close your boat whatever floats your
throat because i'm married but i think
everyone should do whatever the [ __ ]
they want i don't care
do what you want if it doesn't involve
me
that's a very secure position that's
cool do what you want i don't give a
[ __ ]
do what you want i don't care who you
[ __ ] all right it's usually the insecure
people who are like
no you should have to be just like me
yeah i'm insecure guys very insane
and you're working my anxiety guys
you're just fine
if i can't handle [ __ ] you can't not
eat them
if i can have one [ __ ] for the rest of
my life
everyone gets one belief
that's such a good casey impression that
sounds just like him
really good at impressions really good
at impressions okay
he's out of the group but yes uh did
anyone go through like a player phase or
are you going through her player phase
[ __ ] always baby
that's our live baby
only joe and i are single first and
foremost if you're single you're not a
player you're just single
a player is someone who's playing many
hearts so
if you're sorry if you're single and
you're playing multiple hearts then
you're you're you're a multiple
you're playing one player two player one
player there we go ready player one a
little bit of that
you know and not not by myself that's
for sure
multiplayer multiplayer banana peel
banana peel banana peel
um it's the only reference video game i
know
i know that one but princess peach hey
uh
green mushroom wait do you do you boomer
i boomer you boomer
[ __ ] is that something mario kart we
boomer is the
that word geo literally just said that
to me in the dms she called you boomer
she said okay boomer i don't know what
she called herself i forgot i was
reading it really fast
i was skimming it she blue shelled you
blue [ __ ]
that's a boomer reference is that a blue
ball i thought that was just red and
green
no there's a blue shell it gets the
person in front of the green pill no red
and blue pill red and blue balls
that's that's that's a whole green one
it's not a homing device the red one
it follows you red balls is when you're
free you freed your mind of
of sex you don't need it anymore the
ones that's so inflamed
[Laughter]
the tip is red but the balls are blocked
it's milking the snake doesn't it would
you like this milk in the snake
i was born in the year the snake put the
fangs on it on the cup milk
no okay what's happening what's
happening
it sounds like little lethargic mario
he's a composer a man who behaves
selfishly and irresponsibly in his
sexual relationships with women that
name sounds too cool for what it is dude
like lethargic
it's not the cool name that's a cool
last name i wanna hear his fifth
symphony
yeah say that three times fashion it's
like another word for womanizer kind of
woman
womanizer yeah he's chinese [ __ ] this
happened in china china china uh
so he uh where women are scarce too
true and then women are in low supply
and china right and then your your
experience
to what do the women out there look for
in a in a partner
well when i was there they told you in
2006
they were not ashamed to talk about
how their goal in life is to be with a
wealthy man
so this guy he goes around and he
says that he is a very wealthy person he
also
comes off like a wealthy person dresses
up really nice drives lamborghinis
ferraris
uh you know a lot of materialistic
yeah do you like dudes by any chunks
bro we come in as a package you're gonna
have to ask him i look good in a
passenger seat of a lambo honey
you won't say shotgun you won't say
shotgun
imagine big-ass bart sitting next to a
guy and going where are we going daddy
i want to see it i want to see it
that's so funny all right so yeah so
this woman uh it's a scrawny little guy
with a booster seat i don't want to ruin
the surprise babe
all right so this woman dated this man
for about a year before she realized
that she's been defrauded
of 9 million yuan which is 1.3 million
american dollars wow so she took her
that long huh
yes so a lot of times this guy he would
he would say like oh i'm the son or a
grandson of a powerful public official
and so a lot of his money is inherited
so he doesn't actually have to explain
what he does for a living
right or sometimes it's so ambiguous
sometimes like the what these rich
chinese people do true
you know you just kind of give them
import
yeah and so yeah do they sometimes go uh
tax evasion
and you go oh okay okay okay okay
executive
uh coordinator yeah yeah executive
producer okay
what does that mean all right investor
all right so the crazy part of the story
is that
once she came forward about the fraud
frauding
um the police looked into the story we
looked into him
and they found another woman that
actually reported something very similar
about her being defrauded of millions of
dollars as well
serial lethargic he's not just a player
for the [ __ ]
he's a player for the banker camp yes
now
check it would that be a gigolo uh
i don't know what a driglow is he's a
jiggler
oh wait he's like bigger oh yeah
damn it cancel him
i thought it was nick cannon but i think
it's a collab anyway yeah i think is
yeah
anyways uh so the the kicker here though
is
that woman the second woman that they
found that
had a similar complaint actually lives
in the same building
as the other woman oh wow and as the
story progresses and as more women come
out
another woman from the same building
same apartment building he's a
sexual landlord not a landlord
he for some reason just only targets the
same
apartment building and he totaled 20
girlfriends from this one apartment
building wow at the hot
single rich girls are living on this
that's why he knew that the building had
hella ballers in it it does it does make
sense so in taiwan there's a lot of
skyscrapers right and then you know in
america it's spread out
so beverly hills is a city but in taiwan
like you can have like beverly hills the
building
you know what i mean like all the
ballers and beverly hills the tower you
could be like that yeah like literally
like because like you have like
over a thousand people in one building
but there's no hallways you bump into
somebody like hey
well somebody's building the buildings
are so big does he wear like a little
mustache one day
glasses another day big nose the other
yeah big nose
these little well now there's masks now
there's my dog costume the other day
but if he's dressing all flashy and [ __ ]
exactly it's not hard to spot a luxury
car you know like how many i mean
and if he has one of the girls on his
arm wouldn't the other girl catch him
wait we're [ __ ] i thought we're
[ __ ]
right is that spider-man i feel like
maybe he's slick though maybe he just
[ __ ] them in the room and he doesn't
go out with yeah he doesn't parade
around like that maybe he likes the
thrill of like maybe getting caught
people like that
same building that's [ __ ] up the
building could be like a hundred floors
too
they're very true you know but he's also
thinking
like an asian man and this is a factory
he wants to be efficient
so he's going to knock out all of his
clients in one day
in the same building this building and
then he goes to the next building
yeah it's like a mormon move really
right barry mormon
touches a mormon i wonder how he picked
them up that's why i'm wondering he
singled out women that um well one
he met at a car wash i don't know how
you how you would
strike up a conversation like oh hey
what's up this is my landlord you're
watching the building
oh true maybe oh cause fancy fancy boats
be like you know
that's my lamborghini the craziest part
though he doesn't live in this building
though
he actually he resides in the
countryside oh
where his family is are farmers so he's
dirt poor yeah he's just frauded women
is he bringing
the money money back for the family is
he giving back to the family maybe
i mean robin the family's in on a farm
he's driving a lamborghini ferrari
it's not it
he got the surgery yeah with all the
money i did not hear that part i'm so
sorry i zoned out
yeah yeah that changes everything wait
i'm sorry i'm so sorry that does change
everything so how
does that work you put something in the
penis to make it bigger it's an extender
we talked about it the other day yeah
you glue it
from this to this yup in seconds swipe
up
wow i want to get a brand deal would you
all ever do that get on aliexpress
if it doesn't change the feeling it has
the feeling it's all about the feeling
what is that feeling wonderful i always
wonder
you know because what a guy feels right
i will never know the feeling of like
sucks to be you go like this get grab
your farm and just give it a little tug
that's what it feels like just a little
it's a little stretch oh nice
oh very good oh double time
oh warm goose it's asian
oh dude okay yo eat my face
i don't know because we were doing a
little anime voices we were talking
about robin hood
yeah mr hung what happened does he look
good and all that how did he get off you
have a blurred picture of him
oh my god i know what he looks like okay
he looks pretty cute he looks pretty
cute
we can tell through the pixelation yeah
we can tell okay so yeah that's i like
holding on the right
that's what he looks like um that's what
he drives so his
target though he he figures out which
girl is
uh emotionally vulnerable wow so most of
them just
finished a relationship and they're kind
of like not so good emotionally
and he comes in for the swoop it's like
wedding crashers this guy's good huh
but he's like funeral crashers so then
these girls are buying
him all the things yes that's literally
they're they're funding his lavish
lifestyle and he's got
20 bank accounts basically how does he
do it though if he's the rich guy how
does he get them to pay
uh oh he's rich because of them so he
says that his his parents
are uh public officials and he's even
gone as far to say
that they're in some deep government
problems and that he needs money
to get them out of the problem oh the
old nigerian prince scam thing
yes it it's very vague and i guess these
women are just very
goals this is like the true last thing
with with bill paxton he's like i'm a
[ __ ] spy
i'm a [ __ ] spy you're right
i don't know what you can get away with
oh true lies oh
great lies the movie's true lies yeah oh
yes i do know it oh my goodness
oh my goodness i can't believe i i just
acted like i didn't know it is that the
name of the actor bill passing bill
pastor
the guy who pees himself and then wait i
know
everything about that movie i can't
believe i just uh because literally that
movie
was gone it ends with
him there's a freaking bazooka that hits
um uh
the [ __ ] western bonaventure the
horse the el in the elevator
eliza i know the whole thing you saw the
trailer jamie lee curtis
jamie lee curtis seducing with the
[ __ ] and the rose and then arnold's
in the [ __ ] dark on the chair
sitting like this with the tape recorder
it's hot it's hot it's just before what
happens
his own wife uh oh he they
he she reveals so the light turns on i
think it's revealed
and then she's confused and then also
[ __ ]
what's her name the the asian chick she
hasn't seen this movie
yeah i i can't believe i did you
remembered a lot of the scenes
honestly i love that movie no no i'm not
getting that movie for some reason was
always
on when i was young my dad loved it
take it down thank you dog
that's what dad says yep that's what
bill paxton says too yeah
i was like that quote's not in the movie
i don't know where